in prey the Predator brings some new
deadly toys to play with The Predator is
sporting a new Shield that unfolds from
its Gauntlet if that sounds familiar
then you are likely a fan of the 2018
action adventure game God of War the
game follows Kratos a demigod remnant of
the Greek pantheon of deities one of his
tools of the trade is a slick Shield
that emerges from a gauntlet the God of
War similarities don't stop there Naru
uses an axe that she lobs at her prey
with Precision she affixes a rope to the
weapon so she can recall it with a in of
her wrist katos can recall his acts in
the game much like Thor can summon Muir
speaking with comicbook.com Dan
tractenberg stated I teased a while ago
that I took inspiration from the latest
God of War video game and one is his
shield that you see briefly and the
other is not a predator Gadget but just
the way that Naru wields her axe she
invents something very cool for that
tomahawk